[Música]
[Aplausos]
não se preocupem e nem passou mal ainda
não defender recordou sou médico
emergencista e eu vim aqui pra contar
uma história pra vocês e para anunciar
uma coisa que você não sabe é no brasil
agora existe uma nova especialidade
médica ou seja medicina de emergência
existe um novo profissional chamado é
emergencista vou falar de alguns
conceitos para você entender o que
acontece à quando o médico termina a
faculdade
ele faz o que chama se de uma
especialização
então quando eu quero ser cardiologista
eu vou fazer especialização em
cardiologia e essa especialização
chama-se residência médica
pelo amor de deus tem nada a ver com o
apartamento do cara nem com a casa na
praia é residência um treinamento que o
profissional faz e 34 57 anos para se
especializar naquela função bom então no
brasil nós temos o cardiologista
pneumologista proctologista psiquiatra
várias especialidades
quando você cada um de vocês
provavelmente vai a um cardiologista
você vai ter com a certeza que aquele
profissional é um profissional
competente porque ele fez a assistência
médica passou três anos 45 para
treinando para poder atender vocês o que
ocorre no brasil e aí pergunto a vocês
quando vocês vão à emergência o médico
que atendeu vocês pois é agora tem um
médico emergencista a medicina de
emergência ela é uma realidade em mais
de 100 países no mundo e no brasil não
era até 2016 a rigorosidade com essa
especialidade é tão grande
a residência médica por exemplo na nova
zelândia são sete anos muito maior
inclusive do que a própria graduação
então eu vou contar pra vocês
prepare o seu coração que eu vou contar
pra vocês uma história de como se
transformou a medicina é uma medida de
emergência especialidade
aqui no brasil foram quase 20 anos de
luta e conflitos e brigas de tapas de
processos e etc para que a gente
conseguisse transformar a medicina de
emergência numa especialidade para que
nós tivéssemos esse médico emergencista
que é o que é o médico que foi treinado
para atender todas as doenças graves e
agudas e que põe em risco a sua vida
então quando vocês partir de agora
procurar uma emergência
pergunte-se aí tem um médico
emergencista porque vocês nós temos três
certezas na vida eu o diesel está certo
você não tudo bem eu tenho certeza na
vida
não é que eu vou morrer a outra é pra
vocês que vocês vão passar na emergência
um dia ou com você e com a familiar ou
um amigo vão passar a emergência um dia
e outro para garantir uma noite dormi
muito boa nunca vamos separar da mulher
[Aplausos]
eu vou contar um pouco dessa história
porque a história da medicina de
emergência se entrelaça na minha vida
assim como a pele ea tatuagem a manteiga
eo pão tapioca eo café sexto maior
capital que hoje é fraca e isso nós é
bom os três vão acreditar mas quando eu
tinha seis meses vira eu já pensava em
ser médico e disse que o meu pai pai eu
quero ser médico
eu sei que vocês não acreditaram mas meu
pai também acarretam não falou nada
ficou calado
aí eu não quis prolongar o papo aqui
nesse tempo e na realidade eu queria uma
madeira
então deixei para lá a coisa mas quando
foi sim pelos seis sete oito anos
aí sim aí eu realmente definir que a
minha vida que eu ia ser médico que a
minha meta é ser médico é médico pra
quem salva vidas para diminuir a dor
para diminuir o sofrimento e se nada
mais der certo pelo mesmo chorar junto e
aí comecei a estudar chega o vestibular
me lembro como se fosse hoje estava na
minha rede no quarto quarto tinha os
livros todo com matéria bem legal zin
definido a noite ouvindo aquele rádio
fio como se aqui alguém conhece um rádio
fio pretão grandão aparecer na televisão
e locutor disse lá vamos agora mostrar a
anunciar os aprovados no curso de
meditação
aí o cara ainda repetiu medicina e aí
começou o primeiro lugar michael jackson
da silva moreno segundo lugar a fred o
pa média olate terceiro longa
lei de gargalhar e jo quarto lugar
fugiram na kombi eles não sabiam é que
responder no ceará mas se tiver nós
somos os melhores e chegou a 54 aí sim
chamou frederico carlos de souza doha e
o pato e passei no vestibular da
universidade federal e foi digo pra
vocês que foi a maior alegria da minha
vida talvez só comparado ao nascimento
dos meus filhos nada nenhuma prova que
eu tenha feito ou outra vez um curso ou
obtido cargos me deu aquela sensação
maravilhosa tão gostosa cohen foi
sensacional um ponto marcante muito na
minha vida tão marcante que eu tenho uma
coisa pra contar que eu nunca contei a
ninguém talvez só meus familiares
eu tinha um irmão pequeno e cinco anos
que ele ficava feito lobo mau o dia no
quarto era país colhendo ao quarto e eu
praticamente não deixava meu amigo
depois que sair o resultado eu abrir a
porta entrarei amigos palitot escolheu
hábito faça xixi tudo limpinho bumbum
com ele
foi aquela mãe de esculhambação outra
coisa eu tinha prometido tinha prometido
que eu ia andando de messejana ou seja
não bairro aqui é josé de alencar um dos
maiores romancistas do brasil até o
centro da cidade está mais ou menos 17
quilômetros
quando acordei aliás eu acordei eu não
consegui dormir mas quando foi 6 horas
da manhã eu disse rapaz eu vou pagar
logo essa promessa enquanto eu for
porque senão pagar agora um para um mas
nunca vou ficar devendo
e aí fui andando cheguei no centro
um professor do colégio me ver e já vai
dizendo fred você passou esse professor
sou parado não está jogando bola ali na
esquina da quadra com os meninos
eu tava tão suado que não era um toalha
não precisa do outro para tirar né
e aí fiz a faculdade né faculdade muito
boa mas difícil todo mundo sabe disso
é uma faculdade pensada 40 horas todo
toda coisa e houve uma mudança em 1996
quando eu passei no concurso público
para um hospital de trauma que o
instituto josé frota mas chamado
carinhosamente defrontam e as pessoas me
parabenizavam assim é é a paz ou né vai
por vietnã china e quando foi passei me
deparei por aquelas cenas que vocês
provavelmente só vêem nas televisões nos
filmes americanos né bala pra todo lado
faca na barriga exposta tc é tal a
cabeça cascudo sangue espirrando né
tentativa de suicídio facada no pescoço
gente morrendo a zoada sangue espirrando
na cara aquela confusão toda
rapaz quando eu vi aquilo ali eu me
apaixonei
a partir daí é aquela música né
quando vi me apaixonei mas eu me
apaixonei de forma tão profunda e tão
densa que eu dormia para sonhar
emergência e eu acordava para trabalhar
e emergência
o fundo é um amor que até hoje e tudo o
que eu fiz na minha vida profissional de
lá até aqui está diretamente relacionado
com a medicina legista eu estar aqui
hoje eu estar aqui hoje está diretamente
relacionado com esse processo é da
medicina de emergência
então minha vida começa a ter uma nova
diferença necessitam neste aspecto essa
coisa que a gente vê eu disse vamos
melhorar isso aí como é que faz para dar
o melhor pra para transformar esse
ambiente tão caótico tão difícil e aí
fundamos aqui em 98 e mais alguns
colegas do torrão melhora uso on line
beck estão nessa foto
formamos o grupo do ceará ea informamos
a primeira e aí o ceará muito importante
nesse processo porque ninguém pode falar
de cinema do brasil sem falar no nosso
ceará jamais e todos os livros que vão
ser inscrito no futuro o ceará estará
presente como protagonista forte como é
o sertanejo a nós fomos nessa sociedade
e começamos a loucura fazer curso ou
nada palestras por todo canto e aquela
coisa aquela loucura vão estudar
medicina e emergência
vamos melhorar isso aqui uma vez aos
fluxos a logística como é que faz para
atender melhor o paciente
e aí começamos a trabalhar e formar esse
curso e em 2007 um evento muito
importante o que era em 2007 aconteceu
com o 1º congresso vai ter de emergência
no brasil em gramado e aí um cara vocês
vão ver que eu vou receber vários
telefonemas daqui pra frente um cara me
liga no gaúcho
dizendo oh oh oh ok estou é a gente vai
fazer um congresso e eu queria que se
ouve as principais o pato dentro e aí
está na página como é que vocês me
acharam aí ele disse não o seguinte eu
estava num congresso em buenos aires
falando com australiano eu fui dizer que
só existe mas sim de emergência no rio
grande do sul inclusive porque lá foi
fundada a primeira residência médica em
medicina de emergência extraoficialmente
lá estão os gaúchos são parabéns para os
gaúchos que foram os pioneiros na
fundação das residências no treinamento
para esses médicos legistas
olha só as conexões cerebrais ocorrer aí
gaúcho falando em buenos aires com o
australiano que liga o cearense
veja só as conexões como aconteceu esse
foi importante também porque as pessoas
que falavam de emergência separados não
sabiam que existia rio grande do sul não
sabia do ceará do jogo do são paulo e
rio de janeiro não sabia que tinha
residência lá no rio grande do sul
e aí pela primeira vez nós nos reunimos
para traçar as estratégias de
transformar a medicina emergência em uma
especialidade e aí desse congresso sae
a fundação da média a associação
brasileira de medicina de emergência que
a sociedade hoje que comanda e vai
comandar todo esse projeto de
transformação nas nossas emergências e
que eu tenho o privilégio de hoje se o
seu presidente
esse rapaz que está ao meu lado ator
luís alexandre do rio grande do sul
dos grandes guerreiros nessa batalha
também me chamou pra afundar abramede lá
no rio grande do sul de itá quarta feira
tarde só não fundar a quebra média manhã
até mesmo vai ter uma festa na recepção
um churrasco aí muito bom ele não vai
ter uma coca cola aqui com os bolinhos
se quiser vir também fui fui lá à tarde
nós fundamos a sociedade
de noite eu voltei para fortaleza e aí
eu saí daquele congresso com duas
promessas que eu ia afundar uma
residência médica igual à deles água do
rio grande do sul
e aí eu chego aqui no ceará recebo
telefonema
olha o secretário de saúde
o estado está querendo falar com o
senhor disse tô dentro vou lá foi lá ele
me convidou para ser o coordenador
estadual de urgência e emergência e
aceitei foi aí que eu criei a primeira a
segunda residência do brasil que é essa
aí tem alguns residentes da ilha outra
outra promessa foi a fundaç a realização
do 2º congresso brasileiro de medicina
de emergência e foi aqui em fortaleza
foi um sucesso ea medicina agência vai
crescendo e aí as autoridades agentes
médica começa a chamar a gente e aí
chama a conversar o cfm o cfm começa a
ouvir que existe um um movimento que
está querendo criar a medicina de
emergência no brasil até então não
tínhamos é é nada e eles fizeram três
eventos nacionais para poder fazer essa
definição
chamaram a gente conversar o que é que
vocês querem é que vocês não querem ea
gente quer que a medicina é uma agência
especializada no brasil porque é bom o
paciente é bom com o médico é bom para o
sistema de saúde
e aí só mais 2016 foi que eles mostraram
o documentação realmente toda a vida que
eu mostre esse documento eu vou olhar
lado da praia até porque têm leis aqui
não tenho está lá em 29 medicina de
emergência têm medo de triano
mas aí foi festa festa em todo o brasil
isso aí vai se até 20 anos de luta
debate conversas dizendo é preciso mudar
esse sistema que nós temos na medicina
de emergência brasileira é preciso que
tenhamos um médico emergencista
atendendo a população brasileira e nós
estamos aqui para exigir que a população
seja bem atendida seja atendido com
qualidade
ganhamos um presente 16 minutos
no mais um dos maiores
é é programa de televisão da maior rede
de tv do brasil 15 minutos 16 minutos e
terminamos com isso foi expandido para
todo o brasil as pessoas começaram a
comentar o que é isso aí medicina de
emergência ou quer pular como é que vai
ser isso com esse reconhecimento tem
esse médico é mais ou menos isso que eu
contei aqui e é preciso que agora esse
projeto esse processo seja de todos
vocês
não é só de uma sociedade não é só de
uns médicos é da população é das
instituições médicas de todos porque dá
atenção a vocês
cuidar bem salvar bem esse é o nosso
lema
e para terminar deixar sua gestão
se eu pudesse dar como grande disso eu
pudesse dar uma sugestão vocês eu diria
o seguinte
amem a sua arte
amem a sua ciência
a man o seu emprego e nunca jamais
desista dos seus sonhos
esse sonho é feito com amor verdadeiro
jamais você será derrotado
porque o amor vence tudo e eu termino
dizendo de uma frase que me acompanhou
todos esses anos 20 anos esse amor que
nós dedicamos a todos os pacientes
eu queria dizer emergência já que o amor
é para sempre
[Aplausos]